hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game you guys requested uh
it's also from yesterday yesterday was
arrested defeated candidates tournament
so uh other other things took place and
what's one such thing is that magnus
carlsen came to a park and started uh
you know playing chess against everyone
and the one of his opponents was none
other than judith polgar uh now the two
of them have played many games uh
together and when i say many i mean uh
like maybe 25 i'm gonna check i don't
want to trick you uh just to be uh
absolutely certain uh but yeah okay they
played 17 games together uh and uh in
their classical encounters magnus cross
in one two games um uh you did one zero
games in one game ended in a draw but in
rapid time format uh you did get uh one
very nice victory that we've shown on
the channel if you haven't seen it do
check it out i will put a link to it in
the description below but this game uh
only 19 moves but it's uh just an
incredible incredible attacking game you
guys will love this one this is the
venue so you guys can enjoy that for a
moment as well uh what uh what a great
day to be alive and to be a spectator in
this audience uh you know just uh
soaking in all of this uh all of this
power on the board uh it's a beautiful
game you guys uh uh wait and and see uh
so it's a three minute blitz game uh
let's check it out you did has the white
pieces and she opens with pawn to e4 we
have c5 by magnus ghost going for the
sicilian defense knight to f3 e6 now now
going for the sort of a french variation
of the sicilian and the d4 captures
captures knights to c6 knights to c3 and
now pawn to a6 going for the timeout of
variation bishop to e3 the boss recover
line uh and now queen to c7 queen to c7
actually the bostical line uh we have
queen to d2 and knight to f6 and now
pawn to f3 oh they're all very standard
stuff um played a lot today even though
castle in queenside is uh by far the top
move played today but you did goes for
f3 uh strengthens the four pawn and now
if magnus for example plays the bishop
e7 castles then used is ready to start
marching her pawns on the king side and
magnus will of course start marching his
pawns on the queen side b5 bishop b7
rook c8 pawn to b4 and so on uh so here
bishop to e7 not the immediate b5 magnus
first goes for bishop to e7 and the unit
castle's queen side so now unit is ready
to attack the question is only whether
she will attack in the center of the
board or on the king's side and magnus
starts with b5 we have pawn to g4 and
now magnus plays knight captures on d4
uh no doubt you if you play the ceiling
or if you play against the sicilian a
lot you had this position where black is
attacking on the queen side wide on the
king's side and if black goes for the
premature b4 then uh you you can just
put your knight on a4 and that's
perfectly fine there's nothing wrong
with this if queen to a5 you don't
really care you can just defend it with
b3 or even capture play b3 and this
knight is just um spectacular here no no
really good way to get rid of it uh
black will have to play some like c5
bishop to d7 to just threaten the knight
but that that's a whole lot of moves and
the black king is still in the center of
the board so instead after g4 magnus
goes for knight captures bishop captures
and the bishop to b7 and this is only
move 11
but the position has been reached quite
a few times between some very very
strong players for example uh dominguez
played the g5 here against danish geary
that game in the uh ended in a draw uh
sergey karakin uh also had this position
against the wrestling topalov queen to
f2 was played at topalov won that game
uh so many strong players had this
position uh on the board but the movie
unit plays has never been played before
usually plays e5 and it is now already
as of move 12 that we have a completely
new game so what's the idea behind e5
well you've cleared the e4 square for
your knight and you will be controlling
these two squares very nicely and now if
magnus goes for something like knight to
d5 we can play knight to e4 we control
these two squares but it's nothing
serious white i mean black is perfectly
fine here the knight can come to b4 and
already black is putting some pressure
on white
but magnus does not go for knight to d5
after this e5 move magnus goes for
knight captures on g4 he accepts you
that spawn sacrifice
and that is a very dangerous thing in
itself of course now the knight cannot
be captured because the rook hangs unit
still has not connected her rooks so now
rook g1 attacks the knight and now
magnus goes for knight to h6 another
another way to play this would be to
accept even this pawn with bishop
captures on f3 but this would be you
know neglecting your development a bit
too much going for material even though
the engine really says it's perfectly
fine in a three-minute blitz game you
can't really play this enough bishop g2
so now if let's say bishop captures the
bishop captures an a88 magnus will not
be castling queenside and also you don't
really want to castle king side and
after knight captures an h2 grabbing
another pawn defending the bishop then
yuri would have this uh really really
awesome queen to f4 move now just
attacking everything for example bishop
captures on d1 we captured the rook on
a8 and now after the bishop goes back uh
we're just gonna capture the knight here
for example the queen captures pawn to
f5 defends the bishop
and we get this really really uh weird
position where now ambassador is
impossible because of queen captures an
h2 but you know equal-ish position uh
but you don't want to
try something like this against a
natural-born attacker like you did so
magnus goes knight back to h6 and now we
have bishop to d3 now the rooks are
connected and with this bishop the d3
move unit sets a deadly trap for magnus
for example if magnus castles king side
here then rook captures on g7 and the
magnus can just resign
because after king captures rook to g1
check there are no good moves for you
whatever you play queen captures here
and now there's no defense against queen
g7 checkmate and also queen to h7
checkmate so magnus can to do this but
magnus uh uh not really a stranger to
defending difficult positions he just
plays bishop to f8 it is the absolute
strongest move recommended by the engine
defends the g7 pawn and he says my
position is perfectly fine with bishop
to e4 by you did now uh grabbing more
squares here also hoping for for a trade
so the knight can go uh to this
beautiful e4 square then to d6 maybe on
in the future uh and magnus has to uh
you know uh tread very carefully uh for
some reason in previous videos i always
said threat carefully and then some of
you said it's not threat careful it's
actually tread carefully which makes
sense i have no idea why i was saying
threat carefully it's just one of those
things i guess but okay that's a
completely different topic uh but here
magnus has to play bishop captures on e4
and the game continues uh with you maybe
even capturing f captures an e4 opening
up the f file for the rooks but magnus
plays probably what can only be
described as the worst move magnus
carlsen ever played and that is rook to
c8 we can even make this a thumbnail
because it's i mean it's just
spectacular
and now you did is completely winning
but you have to pause the video and try
to figure it out for yourself so feel
free to pause the video and win the game
for you while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on realizing that the
queen is the only
piece guarding the d7 pawn if the queen
is not guarding the d7 pawn and this
bishop isn't here then we just play
queen captures on d7 checkmate and for
you this is you know she sees uh stuff
like this in a blink of an eye and she
immediately played bishop to b6 so
congratulations to everyone who found
this uh there is no defense against this
and now magnus can just resign because
if you move the queen anywhere or you
just capture this then queen captures
and d7 is checkmate so a really really
awesome stuff
and if you don't play this uh of course
magnus didn't magnus played bishop
captures on e4 but now comes the bishop
captures on c7 unit is now up a queen
bishop back to c6 and bishop to d6
magnus played a knight to f5 now comes
knight to e4 and he was in this position
on move 19 that magnus carlsen resigned
the game as there is no point continuing
this game uh you know he's down a queen
and there is no compensation whatsoever
uh so he he could have resigned
basically on move 15 uh dragging it out
uh until move 19 i guess maybe you know
just to play a few moves but if anyone
asks you basically yeah you did pogo
just completely destroyed magnus
crossing in 15 moves which is uh which
is just incredible i mean if you look at
this game how it went uh first playing
uh c5 the sicilian against such a strong
attacker like you did then uh going into
this e5 line uh that has never been
played before and then now you know not
going for for the safe knight d5 but
magnus accepts the challenge and starts
grabbing pawns against you did uh you
know uh that that that's uh simply it is
simply impossible to play like this
against such a such a strong attacker
and then in the end completely
blundering with this rook to c8 i'm
pretty sure like if we checked all of
the moves that magnus played in okay
this is maybe not an official game but
it's official enough he's playing a
serious game against judith polgar it's
a three-minute blitz game you know they
have clocks they have everything uh i'm
pretty sure this is the the absolute
worst move magnus ever played as it just
you know
lose it's like blundering a mating one
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it very very nice victory for
for you that um i really can't wait for
the next time two of them face face each
other again as the the games are always
very very enjoyable so for those of you
who still haven't seen the the other
game where you defeated magnus it will
be the first link in the description
below so do check that out as well uh so
yeah once again i really hope you guys
enjoyed it i would like to thank jeffrey
cook abhishek babui gregory thomas
gideon franklin and jim tran for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of
defeated candidates tournament until it
finishes thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day